♪♪
-Let's get to the news.
President Biden said on Friday
that Russia would pay
"a severe price"
if they used
chemical weapons in Ukraine.
A severe price,
or as it's now known, "premium."
[ Laughter ]
President Biden spoke on Friday
with Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
for nearly 50 minutes.
Zelenskyy asked for more
sanctions against Russia,
like maybe call Putin and keep
him on the phone for 50 minutes.
[ Laughter ]
The head of Russia's
National Guard said yesterday
that the invasion of Ukraine
has been slower than expected.
Oh, interesting. I wonder
what his replacement will say.
"Things are right on track!"
[ Laughter ]
President Biden on Friday
urged House Democrats
to talk up
the party's accomplishments
going into midterm elections.
Said Democrats, "Um,
we got Pelosi's lectern back?"
[ Laughter ]
United Airlines
announced last week
that employees
who were placed on unpaid leave
for refusing to get vaccinated
can return to work
later this month.
So don't worry, your pilot
might be unvaccinated,
but at least
he's also out of practice.
[ Laughter ]
A Florida man
was arrested last week
after he allegedly
called the police
and asked them to test
the crystal meth he purchased
to ensure it was authentic.
[ Laughter ]
Said the man,
"So is that a yes?"
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
"I get one phone call?
I got great news, Scootch!"
[ Laughter ]
During a recent episode
of the competition show
"The Masked Singer,"
a contestant accidentally
knocked their mask off.
Luckily, since it was
"The Masked Singer,"
the judges
still didn't know who it was.
[ Laughter ]
"Oh, it's the guy
from the thing."
[ Laughter ]
Actor Jussie Smollett
was sentenced to five months
in a Chicago jail last week
for staging a hate crime.
Here's what you do, Jussie.
First day in the joint,
walk up to the biggest guy
in there
and say, "Act like
you're beating me up.
[ Laughter ]
It never doesn't work."
According to a new poll,
Seattle is the most desirable
post-graduation city
for college students.
That story again -- Gen Z just
discovered "Frasier" on Peacock.
[ Laughter ]
That story, again --
Karen,
our writer Karen,
just discovered "Frasier."
[ Laughter ]
And finally, a man in Florida --
by the way, I had to separate
our Florida jokes.
[ Laughter ]
We're just going to act
like this is the first one,
but we all remember the crystal
meth guy a few jokes back.
[ Laughter ]
[ Chuckles ]
That guy went first.
When we ordered them,
we were like,
"That one, I think
we can put him early."
And finally, a man in Florida
was arrested last week
after he was
allegedly caught masturbating
in a Miami Beach Starbucks.
Employees suspected
the man was unhinged
the moment he ordered
a Starbucks breakfast sandwich.
[ Laughter ]
In the end,
it was a joke about Starbucks.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
West Virginia Senator
Joe Manchin announced yesterday
that he opposes
President Biden's nominee
for the Federal Reserve Board,
before adding,
"But out of curiosity,
who is it?"
[ Laughter ]
The White House said yesterday
that National Security Advisor
Jake Sullivan
had a 7-hour conversation
with a top Chinese
diplomat in Rome.
I hate to be the one
to tell you this,
but seven hours
is a breakup talk.
No one -- no one's ever said,
"Well, my girlfriend and I
were up talking all night,
and she loves the way
I load the dishwasher
and everything's going great."
[ Laughter ]
Tesla CEO Elon Musk
yesterday challenged
Russian President Vladimir Putin
to "single combat."
Oh, come on, give me
somebody to root for.
[ Laughter ]
This is like hearing
the New York Yankees
want to play against Duke.
[ Laughter ]
Iowa Senator Chuck Grassley
said recently
that Senate Republicans
will be fair and thorough
during the upcoming
confirmation hearings
for Supreme Court nominee
Ketanji Brown Jackson
and added, "We're not going
to get in the gutter
like the Democrats did."
Though, to be fair,
they only got in the gutter
because that's where
Brett Kavanaugh passed out,
so...
[ Laughter and applause ]
Mayor Eric Adams joined the
social media platform
TikTok yesterday
and said in his first video,
"Bing bong, New York City,
your mayor is on TikTok.
Let's get stuff done."
Okay.
Being on TikTok is what we do
when we don't want
to get stuff done.
That's like saying,
"We got a lot of work to do,
somebody fire up 'Elden Ring.'"
[ Laughter ]
That's right, Eric Adams
joined TikTok yesterday
and said in his first video,
"Bing bong, New York City."
Oh, boy.
If Eric Adams
was New York City's dad,
we'd be asking him to drop us
off two blocks away from school.
"Your friends
will love bing bong."
Just, no!
[ Laughter ]
According to a new study,
trained ants may be effective
in detecting cancer in humans,
or at least more effective
than others.
"It's cancer!
Whatever you're typing in
right now, it's cancer!"
[ Laughter ]
Country legend Dolly Parton
announced yesterday
that she will remove her name
from the Rock & Roll
Hall of Fame ballot.
But Dolly is not
going to like this.
They're replacing her
on the ballot with Jolene.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
Head writer Alex Baze and I had
a conversation
right before the show.
We had no idea how that joke
was going to go.
[ Laughter ]
I will say, of the many ways
we thought,
that wasn't one of them.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, in honor
of St. Patrick's Day,
Krispy Kreme will release
four new flavors of doughnuts.
Though, if you really want
to honor the Irish,
I think you do no flavor.
[ Audience groans ]
[ Laughter ]
I mean, to make
a St. Patrick's Day joke
that's not about alcoholism
and is about bad cooking,
I think that shows
some real restraint.
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
Ukrainian
President Volodymyr Zelenskyy
delivered a virtual address
to Congress this morning
and received a standing ovation,
making him the first comedian
to actually deserve one.
[ Laughter ]
Zelenskyy also called
on President Biden
"to be the leader of the world"
and said,
"being the leader of the world
means being the leader
of peace,"
whereas being the leader
of the world
during the Trump years meant
being Angela Merkel.
[ Laughter ]
Second gentleman Doug Emhoff
tested positive yesterday
for COVID-19.
You guessed it --
Phish concert.
[ Laughter and cheering ]
Former President Trump said,
in a new interview,
that he was surprised
when Russian President
Vladimir Putin invaded Ukraine.
Really? 'Cause he invaded
Ukraine in 2014.
When you're surprised by a thing
that's already happened,
that's a symptom.
[ Laughter ]
"Well, you finally came
to see your old grandpa."
[ Laughter ]
I was here yesterday.
"You're as rude as the fella
from yesterday!"
[ Laughter ]
Ohio Governor Mike DeWine
signed a bill into law this week
that allows gun owners to carry
concealed weapons
without a special permit.
Well, what could possibly
go off?
[ Laughter and ohs ]
President Biden signed
a funding bill yesterday
to keep the federal government
running through September.
It was either that
or take a summer job.
[ Laughter ]
He would love that.
The Senate
passed a bill yesterday
that would make Daylight Saving
Time permanent across the U.S.
Finally, a rare victory
for your oven clock.
[ Laughter and applause ]
A man in the UK who was recently
arrested for driving recklessly
gave authorities a LEGOLAND ID
[ Laughter ]
when they asked
for documentation.
They then charged him
with resisting arrest,
when he refused to get
out of the vehicle.
"I can't!
I'm snapped in!"
[ Laughter and applause ]
Senate Majority Leader
Chuck Schumer
and West Virginia
Senator Joe Manchin
reportedly had a secret dinner
last month
at an Italian restaurant
on Capitol Hill
to help repair
their strained relationship.
And I think it might be working.
[ Laughter ]
According to a new survey,
55% of pet owners said
that their dog experiencing
separation anxiety
is their biggest concern
about returning to the office.
"Kids'll be fine, though.
[ Laughter and applause ]
They got each other."
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview,
Rolling Stones guitarist
Keith Richards said
that he quit smoking cigarettes
two years ago.
And if you're wondering
how bad his habit got,
he's 39.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
according to a new study,
older adults who walk
between 6,000
and 8,000 steps a day
are 50% less likely to die early
and 50% more likely to be lost
in a parking garage.
[ Laughter ]
"Where is it, Harold?!"
I don't know, Helen!
[ Laughter ]
♪♪
The annual New York City
St. Patrick's Day Parade
was held today after being
canceled for two years
because of the coronavirus
pandemic.
Of course, they've had
to update the buttons.
[ Laughter ]
President Biden is set
to speak tomorrow
with Chinese President
Xi Jinping
and Biden is all set to remind
China why they need us.
[ Laughter ]
Netflix announced yesterday
that the political satire show
"Servant of the People"
that stars Ukrainian President
Volodymyr Zelenskyy
will return to the platform.
And they're also taking down
Putin's standup special.
[ Laughter ]
[ Russian accent ] Yeah, so just
broke up with girlfriend.
Feel bad.
So I bought her a trip
to Siberia.
This guy knows
what I'm talking about.
President Biden
announced yesterday
that the U.S. will provide a new
assistance package for Ukraine,
which includes 800
anti-aircraft systems.
We're giving them the best
anti-aircraft system we have --
drunk passengers.
[ Laughter ]
[ Slurring ]
I'm not wearing a mask.
[ Laughter ]
A cargo ship named Ever Forward
is stuck
in Maryland's Chesapeake Bay
after running aground
on a sandbar.
And they're really
rolling the dice
by sending the Never Sinks
to save it.
[ Laughter ]
In a new interview
with Bloomberg,
a sanctioned Russian billionaire
said that he now has to live
on $3,300 per month.
That's weird.
They're making him
teach high school?
[ Laughter ]
[ Audience groans ]
Alright. [ Mutters ]
[ Laughter ]
Officials in Spain
recently impounded
a third superyacht
that's believed
to belong to a Russian oligarch,
mostly because they're not
very creative
with their boat names.
[ Laughter ]
Republican Pennsylvania
Senate hopeful Dr. Mehmet Oz
said yesterday
that he would renounce
his dual Turkish citizenship
if he gets elecshed --
elected, excuse me.
No word yet on when
he'll renounce
the title of doctor.
[ Laughter ]
Transportation officials
in New York yesterday announced
plans to raise the flat fee
for a taxi
between JFK Airport
and Manhattan to $65.
That's crazy!
That's almost $15 an hour.
[ Laughter ]
We mathed them.
We fully mathed them.
That's on us.
[ Laughter ]
We didn't even give them pens
and paper or anything.
[ Laughter ]
And finally, tomorrow is
National Awkward Moments Day.
This news first reported
by the guy who was
actually waving to the person
behind you.
[ Laughter ]
And that was a monologue,
everybody.
♪♪
[ Cheering, whistling,
and applause ]